لم تملك هذه السيده سوى الفراري نحو
العاصمه مقديشو بعد ان خطف الموت ثلاثه من
اطفالها بسبب سوء التغذيه الناتجه عن
الجفاف العارمه الذي يضرب البلاد خديجه
معه التي نزحت من منطقه سبلا لبي محافظه
شبل السفلى بالجنوب تعيش في حاله قلقنا
دائما
اخرين تتمنى ان يعيش في حاله افضل في
البيئه الجديده التي تفتقد هي الاخرى الى
ابسط مقومات العيش الكريم
وتوفي ثلاثه من اطفال بسبب الحصبه وسوء
التغذيه وما زال الاطفال هنا يعانون سوء
التغذيه ويزداد وضع اطفال النازحين سوءا
يوما بعد اخر مع اشتداد حاله الجفاف في
البلاد حيث لا تتوقف حركه النزوء تجاه
مخيمات على اطراف بحثا عن امن وغذاء
اهلا وسهلا الى هذه المنطقه منذ شهر
ونعاني من الجوع مع اطفالي وام العجوز
نريد دعما عاجلا خاصه للضعفاء منا
وبحسب منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله فان
معادله وفيات الاطفال نتيجه سوء التغذيه
في الشمال يشهد ارتفاعا مخيفا وان الوضع
اسوا من ما كان عليه عام 2011 عندما تسببت
للمجاعه في وفاه ربع مليون صومالي عبد
الرحمن بخاري العربي